my [ __ ] and twigs best these savages can
do these are my people now you shouldn't
call them savages I'll call them what I
like because they're my people
this is my army I am a Khaleesi of the
Dothraki I am the wife of the great Khal
and I carry his son inside me the next
time you raise a hand to me will be the
last time you have hands Roszak go off
serve or service and the crowd of is not
a kadai their us on osechi ana Hallisey
and i sake erisa kashi Madri voy de
Bercy and was Xebec
and how koi is that vaasi we will take
back what was stolen from me and destroy
those who wronged me we will lay waste
to armies and burn cities to the ground
I know the opportunity before you seems
like the last you'll ever have but you
must not speak to me like I'm a child
[Music]
she has a talent for drama this one if I
wanted your dragons I would have taken
them they mean nothing to me on their
own nothing they're more valuable than
anything in the world
you were too young to be so and you what
you familiar Rocky you have with you
this Josie revoir okay ball
the Dothraki you have you're both here
to advise me I value your advice but if
you ever question me in front of
strangers again you'll be advising
someone else is that understood Guidry
says boost Darice goes down
[ __ ] dinette is Kjell Magne enter Gary
all interest in veneer awake Ohana
gothic Sun Valley real moon Ewing was
new easy son I'm looking for you when
this is over
Sorbara student it comes to battle kill
that one first
gladly your grace I have loved you
no how can you say that to me any other
man and I would have him executed but
you I do not want you in my city dead or
alive please don't ever presume to touch
me again or speak my name get him out of
my sight please did he have an
opportunity to confess his betrayal yes
many opportunities and did he know but
until forced to do so he is in love with
you I think so I should kill him hey get
your fee your evo said she arrived at
the river
[Music]
do we have a plan I will crucify the
Masters I will set their fleets of fire
kill every last one of their soldiers
and return their cities to the dirt that
is my plan
Lord Varys has proven himself a loyal
servant proven himself loyal quite the
opposite if he dislikes one Manik he
conspires to crown the next one what
kind of a servant is that we're children
playing it again screaming that the
rules aren't fair he told me you liked
this man I do in the time since he's met
me he's refused to call me queen he's
refused to bow and now he's calling me a
child your strategy has lost us dawn the
Iron Islands and the reach if I have
underestimated our enemy my enemies your
family you mean nothing Scrubs bold
notions for any man's head like a few
weeks in the dark sir I'm not here to
put men in Chains if that becomes an
option many will take it and I saw
hundreds of arrows miss but any one of
them could have found your heart and
ended she's been thinking about my death
quite a bit haven't you is this one of
the items you discussed with your
brother in Kingsland I'm trying to serve
you by planning for the long term
perhaps if you planned for the short
term we wouldn't have lost Dorne
Highgarden
he came here alone knowing full well how
he'd be received why would he do that
perhaps he trusts his little brother to
defend him right up to the moment he
slits my throat Circe still sits on the
throne if you can't help me take it back
I'll find another hand who can
the next time you fail me be the last
time you fail me
[Music]
Selina Jakarta's
[Music]